well there's a new bombshell report out
today from the former head of the DNC
tearing the DNC apart we'll talk about
it plus the Republican tax bill and
President Trump goes after immigration
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show all righty so this donna Brazile
report in Politico is pretty astonishing
for a number of reasons I'm gonna go
through them and it just demonstrates
how in the tank the media war for the
Democratic Party it's a little of this
came out over the past couple of years
during the center of the election cycle
it does demonstrate also how in the tank
the DNC was for Hillary Clinton and how
Bernie Sanders really got jobs and
furthermore it demonstrates why Bernie
Sanders is the future of the party but
I'll explain all of that in just one
second first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at Dollar Shave Club
so you've heard me talk about using
Dollar Shave Club products I've used
everything from their body cleanser and
their hair gel to their razors under the
chin and it is just fantastic stuff
Dollar Shave Club makes products for
your hair face skin shower everything
you need it's all their own original
stuff and they use only the finest
premium ingredients they deliver it
directly to you just like they do their
razors so no longer do you have to make
these annoying trips to the store trying
to figure out what all of these things
do now Dollar Shave Club provides you
pretty much everything that you need
razors body cleanser hair gel and yes
even their fabled butt wipes now is a
great time to give Dollar Shave Club a
try you can get your first month of
their best razor along with travel sized
versions of shaved butter body cleanser
and yes those magnificent butt wipes for
just $5 after that replacement card for
just shipped for just a few bucks a
month it is the DSC starter set get
yours for just five dollars exclusively
at dollarshaveclub.com slash pen that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash been best
shave you'll ever have plus all of their
other materials are just as good
dollarshaveclub.com slash been and
that's what you and with that you get $5
there there's their starter set for just
$5 which includes all of their the first
month of their razor along with the
travel sized versions of all that other
awesome products so go check it out
right now dollarshaveclub.com slash then
okay so we begin with this bombshell
report from Donna Brazile so you
remember Donna Brazile Donna Brazile was
a CNN commentator former part of the Al
Gore campaign in 2000 and she was made
interim head of the Democratic National
Committee
after Debbie wasserman-schultz was
basically ousted for handing the DNC
over to Hillary Clinton and using it as
a weapon against Bernie Sanders and
Donald L had already at that point I
believe been leaking questions to
Hillary Clinton to bake questions to
Hillary Clinton from the CNN desk before
the debate she was actually let out of
her CNN contractors who's essentially
fired as is if I recall and she is now
coming out trying to explain that she is
not at fault right she is fine it's just
the DNC that was a wreck and what she
has to say about the Democratic National
Committee really does demonstrate that
the sort of division that I was talking
about I've been talking about for a year
now on this show the the tripartite
division inside the DNC the division
between Hillary followers Obama
followers and Bernie followers is very
real and that Bernie is actually winning
this battle so here are some of the
revelations from Zhanna Brazil's piece
at Politico this is from her new book
that is that is coming out shortly
first of all Brazil is obviously trying
to shield herself she's obviously doing
me I'm shocked shocked to find there's
gambling going on here routine she
portrays herself as Hercule Poirot you
know as encyclopedia brown entering the
situation and trying to determine where
the malfeasance has been at the TNC like
she didn't know she she talks in this
article about it's a week before the
election and she's been sussing out how
Bernie Sanders got screwed and she is
just so devastated by it she says that I
love this just before I called Bernie
Sanders I lit a candle in my living room
and put on some gospel music I wanted to
censor myself for what I knew would be
an emotional phone call I mean really if
you're gonna write a movie about
yourself try not to make it so cliche
Donna really that you put on candles you
lit candles and put on gospel music
really oh come on yeah I guess if she'd
been the villain she would have put on
Beethoven right that's the way that all
the bad movies work in any case this is
the same lady because I say leads to
bait questions to Hillary now claiming
that she was trying to just bring
honesty to the Democratic National
Committee Debbie wasserman-schultz her
predecessor was a disaster who turned
the entire party over to Hillary
according to Brazil she says my
predecessor Florida representative
debbie Wasserman Schultz had not been
the most active chair and fundraising at
a time when Barack Obama's neglect had
left the party in significant debt as
Hillary's campaign gained momentum she
resolved the party's debt and put down a
starvation diet it had become dependent
on
campaign for survival for which she
expected to wield controls of its
operations so according to Brazil
basically what happened is that the
Democratic Party had run up on hard
times
Obama had cleaned the place out and
Debbie wasserman-schultz didn't want to
do the fundraising so instead she went
to Hillary and said you do all the
fundraising you fill back in that hole
you you back fill that gap in our
funding and I'll let you run the DNC
basically this is according to Donna
Donna Brazile all the Bernie people who
are complaining that the thing was
rigged all up from statements that it
was rigged against Bernie all of that
was true third point here Obama cleaned
out the party so for all of the talk
about how Barack Obama was the great
savior of the Democratic Party they the
new FDR the man who had revitalized the
Democratic Party not only sin Obama
devastate the Democratic Party down
ballot losing over a thousand state
seats and legislators across the country
losing 13 gubernatorial seat moving 12
Senate seats not only did he do all of
those things he also cleaned them out
financially Brazil says that by the time
she took over the DNC the Democratic
Party was broke and two million dollars
in debt this is in the middle of an
election cycle where Hillary is raising
poodles and gobs of cash according to
Brazil Obama after - after 2012 left the
party 24 million dollars in debt 24
million dollars in debt okay Barack
Obama that great that great beacon of
light for the Democratic Party
he basically bankrupted the party and
his campaign said they wouldn't pay it
off until 2016 so what did they do
Wasserman Schultz had grown the staff
right she actually grew the staff she
didn't cut and put the party on a
starvation diet she grew the staff and
allowed the DNC to pick up the check for
Obama consultants so Obama had already
run the party into the ground but the
DNC was continuing to pay using the
credit card for all of Obama's
consultants which is pretty amazing
so what happened they turned it over to
Hillary and Hillary was supposed to come
in and fill in the gap so Hillary used
that debt to pick up power Gary Gensler
who's the the chief financial officer of
the Hillary campaign
apparently quote described the party as
fully under the control of Hillary's
campaign which seems to confirm the
suspicions of the Bernie camp the
campaign had the DNC on life support
giving him money every month to meet his
basic expenses while the campaign was
using the party as a fundraising
clearinghouse and here's where you get
into some dicey territory Hillary
Clinton was apparently using the DNC
almost almost to launder mine
I mean not not in a strict legal sense
but in a sort of colloquial sense she's
basically using the DNC to launder money
here is here's what Brazil explained is
less than 1/2 of 1% of all the money
that Hilary raised for the DNC actually
went to the state parties instead it
I'll roll right back into campaigning
for Hillary Brazil says when the
political story described this
arrangement is court essentially money
laundering for the Clinton campaign
Hillary's people were outraged at being
accused of doing something shady
Bernie's people were angry for their own
reasons saying this was part of a
calculated strategy to throw the
nomination to Hillary which of course it
was all the money was coming into the
DNC vzv Hillary and it wasn't being used
for Democratic Party operations it was
being used to campaign for Hillary
Rodham Clinton personally so they let
Hillary have run to the shop and she
immediately corrupted the DNC in the
same way that she corrupted the State
Department in the same way the Clinton
Foundation was corrupt all of which
leads to the sixth point here Bernie got
completely jobbed
okay Bernie got completely jobs if the
DNC had not hands in all of its
operations over to Hillary to the point
where Hillary for America was basically
running the DNC from Brooklyn from her
Brooklyn offices every press release
from the DNC apparently had to be vetted
through Hillary's office if that had not
been happening
Bernie probably wins the nomination or
at the very least it's an
extraordinarily close race even closer
than it ended up being Brazil basically
admits that Hillary was in charge of the
DNC from August to 2015
August 2015 the first primaries didn't
put take place until January 2016 so
before Bernie was even seriously running
the party had been turned over to
Hillary Clinton a candidate for the
nomination which is insane Brazil says
quote the funding arrangement with HFA's
Hillary for America and the victory fund
agreement was not illegal but it sure
looked unethical if the fight had been
fair one campaign would not have control
of the party before the voters had
decided which one they wanted to leave
and all this leads to the final point
here it is very obvious that Bernie
Sanders lost the battle in 2016 but he
absolutely won the war
if Bernie and won the nomination maybe
he doesn't beat Trump right maybe he's
just a crazy old loon bag Socialist from
Vermont who couldn't defeat Donald Trump
and Hillary is sitting somewhere crying
into her beer and we get Hillary running
again in 2020 but Bernie Sanders didn't
win the nomination and now the
widespread perception apparently correct
is that Bernie Sanders was cheated out
of the nomination by the Democratic
Party establishment and so Bernie can
now run as the anti-establishment
outsider again in 2020 and as the loyal
soldier because according to Brazil she
went to Bernie with all of this one week
prior to the election Bernie didn't say
I want to blow this up I'm gonna go
public with this instead Bernie
swallowed hard and he said I'm gonna
campaign for Hillary against Trump
if Bernie runs for the nomination in
2020 he will win the nomination in 2020
and he may win the presidency which is
very scary for the country very
frightening for the country okay but
Bernie Sanders is now where the power
lies in the Democratic Party and Brazil
is making that clear Donna Brazile is a
political animal Donna Brazile is a
political survivor and what she is doing
here is she's basically tossing Hillary
Clinton to the wolves so that she can
get in good with the Bernie Sanders
folks who she feels her the next wave in
the Democratic Party and you can see
this right all of the major Democratic
players in 2020 are already endorsing
Medicare for all they're already moving
along Bernie Sanders lines trying to
outflank Bernie Sanders good luck with
that
their only hope is that Bernie stays out
of the primaries in 2020 and then
endorses someone that is their only hope
if Bernie runs in 2020
he will win the Democratic nomination
he'll defeat Joe Biden he will defeat
Kamala Harris for sure Bernie Sanders
will have the power of revenge behind
him plus Bernie Sanders has a better
feel for what voters want to hear in
some of the swing states that Hillary
lost than Hillary Clinton said there's a
significant possibility that Bernie
Sanders is president in 2020 because of
Hillary Clinton okay that's not scary to
you and you haven't been following
Bernie Sanders career in any significant
way so that's the news out of out of
democratic land where they've torn each
other apart Bernie Sanders devastate her
knee Sanders owns the party because
Hillary Clinton corrupted the party and
Barack Obama bankrupted the party and
Bernie Sanders is the only solution
pretty amazing stuff pretty amazing
switch from a guy who was at the fringe
or the Democratic Party basically now
being the center of gravity inside of it
well I want to talk a little bit about
the new tax proposal that Republicans
just put out I think it's quite good but
it's quite bad for people like me I'll
explain why that is in just a second but
first I want to say thank you to our
friends over at policy genius so life
insurance is something that you should
have if you're an adult I have life
insurance and myself our company has
life insurance on me so if the show
starts to tank and I'm found dead you'll
know who to blame but in any case life
insurance is something that if you are
an adult with a family you should
absolutely have it if you have kids you
owe it to yourself and your family to
have a life insurance policy most people
do not have a good life insurance policy
but policy genius lets you compare life
insurance from the top providers online
it takes as little as five minutes or if
you're busy one minute per day for five
days if you find a policy you like and
you want to know more you can talk to
one of their licensed experts but if
you're just browsing you don't have to
talk to anybody and you just browse away
they don't just do life insurance and
get disability insurance renter's
insurance pet insurance and you can
compare health insurance as well policy
genius makes the business of insurance
and obtaining it incredibly easy and a
lot better than sort of the
non-transparent system that people have
been using before you know they're all
these other sites that compare travel
prices but there's nothing like this for
insurance except for policy genius this
is where policy genius comes in make
sure that you are getting the right
price for the right policy if you need
life insurance but you've been putting
it off
try it it's quick it's easy and it's
something you owe to yourself policy
genius comm you should only be forced to
speak to an agent if you've committed a
federal crime so there's no reason why I
should have to talk to a life insurance
agent but what you should do undoubtedly
is is you should talk you should go and
check out their their varying price
points and see what works best for you
okay so back to the Republican tax plan
here so the Republicans have now
released their tax plan and it's got
some good stuff and it's got some bad
stuff basically if you're in California
no no and you own a home you're screwed
this is basically how this works if
you're anywhere else in the country this
plan is probably quite good for you but
if you are in California
you just get jobs by this plan if you're
in the upper tax bracket so for people
like me I'm in top tax bracket in
California that means I am just going to
get nailed I would vote for this tax
plan anyway because I think the tax plan
is quite good so here's what the tax
plan does it lowers the corporate tax
rate from thirty five percent to twenty
percent this is a good thing it also
lowers the the pass-through tax rate on
what they call S corporations from close
to 40 percent down to 25 percent which
is also a good thing because our
corporate tax rates are the highest in
the industrialized world they are higher
than France they're higher than Japan
they are higher than the UK they are
higher than Germany bring it down to 20%
would put us right in the middle of the
pack that is a good thing it also
narrows the tax brackets right now there
are seven tax brackets this would get
rid of four of them it would bring it
down to or it would get rid of three of
them rather bring it down to four tax
brackets as opposed to as opposed to
seven
it would actually negatively impact
people who are making over $400,000 a
year if you were making over $400,000 a
year than you are paying 39.6% in the
your pay sorry if you're paying no
matter what you're paying 40 percent tax
bracket if you're making about four
hundred twenty thousand dollars a year
this new program would lift that cap to
five hundred thousand dollars a year but
it would also make it that if you're
making more than four hundred thousand
dollars a year you're paying a 33
percent you're paying a 35 percent tax
as opposed to a 33 percent tax so raises
taxes slightly for people in that tax
bracket but then increases the next
station on the on the belt so if you are
if you're making precisely five hundred
thousand dollars this is not necessarily
a good deal for you if you're making
more than five hundred thousand dollars
then the deal is probably fine for you
you don't really lose much through it if
you are making below two hundred
thousand dollars a year your taxes go
down no matter what tax bracket you're
in if you make under thirty seven
thousand dollars a year your tax bracket
goes down from 15 to 12 if you are
making under two hundred thousand
dollars a year your tax bracket goes
down from 28 to 25 the capital gains and
dividend tax rates stay exactly the same
the estate tax is basically chopped in
half so if you are right now you pay the
estate tax I think is evil this idea the
government gets to raid your your coffin
for cash you die the government
immediately runs into your safe and just
takes out the money you've already paid
taxes on pretty terrible but well right
now what this plan would do is to take
the estate tax which is 40% on estates
above five point five million and
doubles it so that the estate tax only
applies on the state's above eleven
point two million and then in 2024 it
just is eliminated completely it just
goes away completely to no more estate
tax which of course is the proper
solution considering that anybody who
knows what they're doing with taxes
simply signs the living will and then
they don't have to pay it in estate tax
anyway right a living will just allows
you to essentially transfer your assets
over before your death to your children
so that way they're not inheriting from
you it's only inheritance that that gets
screwed here the g-o-p tax plan does
repeal the deduction for state and local
income and sales taxes this is why I say
if you're in California you're screwed
okay now I don't think this is a bad
thing I think it's a bad thing for me
all right I think that I'm in trouble
here because California has a ten
percent state income tax
is insane so basically the way that it
used to work is that I would take that
as a deduction against my federal tax
now I can't do that anymore under the
Republican tax plan so basically if I'm
in the top tax bracket or at least the
portion my income that's in the top tax
bracket I'm going to be paying 39.6% on
that and then I'll be paying an
additional 10% on that from the state of
California right which is pretty insane
so I'm paying 50% of all that money to
the state or federal government which is
pretty crazy especially because as I've
said I don't agree with tax plans that
increase taxes on people who are wealthy
because the people who are making a lot
of money are also the people who are
investing a lot of money saving a lot of
money and allowing free Commerce to
flourish that it also allows a deduction
for property taxes but it caps at a
$10,000 so again it punishes people in
California California has some pretty
significant property taxes even though
it's been capped by prop 13 in places
like Massachusetts which have a huge
property tax that is going to just
destroy them the purpose here on a
political level is to force a lot of the
blue states to reconsider whether their
taxes should be quite this high and it
is not fair the Texas has been basically
paying the paying the freight for
California through this particular tax
deduction Republicans are going to
curtail the deductions that is according
to The Wall Street Journal individuals
take for state and local tax payments
and the ones businesses get for the
interest they pay on debt but it doesn't
charge the 401k savings accounts which
is good it also calls for leaving the
top individual tax rate at forty percent
but pushing the income threshold to 1
million for married couples there there
some holes that I think Democrats are
going to try and exploit here the holes
they're going to try and exploit are
again the the failure to take into
account state income taxes and also that
it gets rid of deductions for medical
expenses so people who have HSAs don't
really have to worry about it but if you
have a serious medical problem and
you're paying lots of money and now you
can't take that deduction in the same
numbers you were before that is going to
hurt you and that's where the Democrats
are going to attack they're gonna say
you're killing Obamacare already and now
you're trying to take away my deduction
for the medical care why are you
punishing people who have health
problems that's where the Democratic
line of attack is likely to come so as I
say there are a couple of political
landmines so they're also also speaking
of people who it's gonna hurt in
California and Massachusetts the bill
limits the home mortgage interest
deduction so right now you can take a
mortgage interest deduction for loans up
to a million dollars now it would only
be deductible on loans up to $500,000
well that's not just you know that's not
just rich people in the state of
California basically any home in a major
city in the state of California any
single-family home in the state of
California you're taking a loan about
five hundred thousand dollars or the
average price for a three-bedroom in
like LA is probably 750 so that's gonna
hurt some people who are middle-class
and because of a larger standard
deduction so the standard deduction has
gone up that's kind of the the Matz
deduction you can give fewer people
would have a tax incentive to make
charitable deductions so you used to
give charitable deductions in order to
increase your itemization that is going
to go away a little bit life insurers
lose some tax breaks bank with assets
exceeding 50 billion would get no
deduction taxes on this this is good
actually taxes and bonds can no longer
get a tax deduction for for building
professional sports stadiums and no more
subsidizing the these stupid LA football
teams to build more stadiums and no more
of that overall this is quite a good tax
plan I think that it does pick and
choose in some areas that I don't
exactly love it retains the Earned
Income Tax Credit which is basically a
welfare program it also increases the
child tax credit but not as much as
people like Mike Lee and Marco Rubio
have suggested but under current law a
married couple with two children making
60 grand would get a $13,000 standard
deduction and for personal exemptions
worth $4,100 $4,100 opposed to a
significantly larger tax bill so bottom
line is that it does lower taxes for
virtually everyone except the people or
at the top of the income spectrum and
people living in states like California
and Massachusetts will Trump have a
majority for this you know it's gonna be
difficult for me to cobble together a
majority for anything particularly
because there's the the say no to
anything Trump wants caucus now which
may or may not include people like John
McCain Jeff Flake Lisa Murkowski Susan
Collins we'll see how bad the blowback
is from the Democrats what's interesting
about this proposal is because Trump is
not actually giving tax breaks to people
at the upper end of the income spectrum
like me it's gonna be difficult for the
Democrats to say that he's attempting to
create tax cuts for the rich at the
expense of people lower in the income
scale because that simple
is not true okay so there is your your
tax breakdown now I want to talk a
little bit more about immigration and
president Trump's plans there on where
he is right and why he's right but not
for quite the right reasons but for that
you're gonna have to go over to Daly
wire.com I have a lot to talk about so I
want to talk today about internet
censorship both Republicans and
Democrats are gonna go after some major
Internet companies I have pretty epic
things I hate that I'm going to talk
about we're gonna go after Stephen
Colbert a little bit so lots to talk
about here but for $9.99 a month you can
get a subscription to daily wire.com you
get the rest of my show live on video
you get the rest of manutuke Levens show
live on video at 10:30 you get the rest
of michael Knowles's show live on video
at 12:30 plus you get to be part of my
mailbag which we are doing tomorrow in
which all of your life's questions will
be answered and get to ask me live
questions right you actually get to ask
me questions in the midst of the show
and you can see me respond in real time
to your question so that's pretty
awesome
for $99 you get the annual subscription
so discount from the monthly fee number
one and number two you also get this the
very greatest beverage vessel in the
history of humankind the leftist here is
hot were called tumbler world famous
never duplicated often imitated leftist
here's how to call tumbler so you get
that when you get your annual
subscription if you want to if you want
to just listen to the rest of the show
go over to YouTube and hit subscribe
please there's a lot of new material
that we're releasing nearly every day
over at YouTube that you can't catch us
by subscribing to the audio version or
if you just wanna listen to the audio
for free later you subscribe to youtube
or go to iTunes SoundCloud leave us a
review we always appreciate it we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so yesterday I was talking about this
New York terror attack I want to make a
correction to something that I said sort
of in the heat of the moment I got a
fact wrong I said there are more people
who have been killed by white
supremacists terror attacks in the
United States since 2001 than Islamist
terrorist attacks that of course is not
true there have been more white
supremacist attacks than Islamist terror
attack - overall but the number of
people have been killed in Islamist
terror attacks is greater than the
number of people killed in white
supremacist terror attacks because
they're places like Orlando where he had
59 people killed or I think was 59 right
who are killed in Orlando I'd have to
I'd have to check the number but a solid
number of people who were killed in the
in the Orlando nightclub shooting that
was in Islamic terror attack 58
non-fatal injuries 50 deaths including
the perpetrator
so more deaths in Islamist terror
attacks more attacks by white
supremacist okay so I wanted to correct
the record on that because I think it's
important to correct ourselves when we
make mistakes I also said yesterday that
I didn't think that it was the right
time to talk about immigration policy
mainly because I think that the
immigration policies Trump is espousing
are exactly correct but we have to do
this outside the heat of a terror attack
and here's the reason why I want to show
you so here's Laura Ingraham making the
argument that Trump was making yesterday
with regard to immigration policy now
remember I agree with Laura Ingram's
argument on the immigration policy I
grew at Trump's argument on the
immigration policy but I think the
justification you're about to hear Laura
Ingraham use here is actually a really
problematic one although we can't stop
all terror attacks in the United States
the safety of the American people demand
that we do what we can to stop those
attacks that are preventable 9/11 should
have made it obvious to everyone that
Islam has a hideous radicalization
problem Donald Trump put the onus on
Muslim leaders on his first foreign trip
to get their houses in order and reform
from within here at home we should not
lose one more American life because
politicians don't have the nerve or the
will to do what's necessary to secure
the homeland our safety is their primary
responsibility ok so here's the problem
with what she's saying to a certain
extent of course we should take policies
and minimize terror attacks but this
basically this basically boils down to
we
cannot lose one more life right that's
that's essentially what she's saying
here she's basically saying we cannot
lose one more life you know if this even
saves one more American life right she's
here at home we should not lose one more
American life because politicians don't
have the nerve or well to do what's
necessary to secure the home and that
last line we shouldn't you lose one more
life that's the exact same line that gun
control advocates use when they're
talking about banning guns right if it
saves just one life well I hate that
logic because pretty much everything
could save just one life right I mean if
we ban cars would that save just one
life it's at tens of thousands of lives
in all likelihood right she banned
knives I mean if we did that presumably
would save some lives
Japan swimming pools or buckets there
are lots of things we can do to save
just one life the question is is that
good policy or not so I think Trump's
recommendations on policy here are
basically correct but I think that using
the logic of terror attacks in order to
push for particular policy changes the
problem with using terror attacks is the
same as the problem with using mass
shootings statistically speaking there
are an anomaly that does not mean we
shouldn't take policies that minimize
them but if you're going to use that to
justify broad policy changes then you
know I think that you're gonna end up in
a world of hurt because the logic itself
supports bad policy as well as good
policy you really only want logic that
supports good policy plus we now know
there were red flags about this guy as
always there are red flags one of the
things that's amazing is that you know
in the when they released the JFK
documents it showed that the government
was really nervous about releasing those
documents I think the reason the
government is really nervous about
releasing those documents is they had
all sorts of red flags on oswald for the
same reason the government was nervous
about the 9/11 report for the same
reason the government is always nervous
whenever there's a terror attack and a
report on it there's always the problem
of we botched our job that is usually a
more plausible explanation for why there
was some sort of terror attack or some
sort of shooting or some sort of
assassination a botch in the middle
right that policy that was already on
the books was not enforced that's almost
always a more plausible explanation for
why something happened than a
broad-based policy failure so the
question here is what is the broad-based
policy failure so there are a couple of
broad-based policy failures here but
they are failures not because of an
anomalous terror attack they are
failures because these broad-based
policies have writ broad-based changes
in American social standards and
cultures and mores right so here is
Trump yesterday talking about chain
migration with this New York City
terrorist and what do you
that chain migration is absolutely true
as a general matter and we want to get
rid of chain migration this man that
came in or whatever you want to call him
brought in with him other people and he
was a point he was the point of contact
the primary point of contact for and
this is preliminary twenty-three people
that came in or potentially came in with
him and that's not acceptable so we want
to get rid of chain migration and we've
wanted to do that for a long time and
I've been wanting to do it for a long
time okay and it is right to get rid of
chain migration when he is saying here
as a general rule the big problem with
chain migration is not a bad guy
interest the United States prints in 23
bad relatives right that's see that's
probably not the problem the real
problem here is that but not with
terrorism right people who come in not
necessarily bad people but people come
in with different cultural mores and
then they bring in their entire family
right people who are not educated you
get one guy who comes in through the
diversity Visa Lottery has a high school
degree in two years and work experience
he comes in and he brings his entire
extended family none of whom have any
high school degree or any work
experience none of whom have been
acclimated to Western traditions and
morals and they all come in right chain
migration has always been bad policy
chair migration has always been garbage
policy but it's not garbage policy
necessarily because of this guy it's
been garbage policy for years and this
is why I don't like using sort of single
instances as the excuse same thing here
here's Trump saying he's gonna try and
terminate the diversity lottery I talked
about this yesterday the diversity
lottery the idea that we are going to
give affirmative action to countries
that don't have enough people coming in
is really stupid originally it was
designed to get it to get more Europeans
in it's largely been used for countries
that are that are majority Muslim now
and it's bad policy why should we give
affirmative action to countries why not
just apply individual standards to the
people coming in instead of trying to do
it by ethnicity or country it's a
problem that's the real reason we should
terminate the diversity visa lottery
Trump instead is trying to say that it's
because of the terror attack I am today
starting the process of terminating the
diversity lottery
program I'm going to ask Congress to
immediately initiate work to get rid of
this program diversity and diversity
lottery diversity lottery sounds nice
it's not nice it's not good it's not
good it hasn't been good we've been
against it okay well you know he's right
but again doing this on the back of the
terror attack is my is my problem here
so he's doing the right thing for what I
think is sort of the wrong reason here
but because he's doing the right thing
and because he is saying things that I
think most Americans think this is why
Trump is popular let's be real about
this you know Trump last night tweeted
out that he was very upset obviously
over the attack and he said this
terrorist should get the death penalty
that's it
the president should not say that okay
poisons the jury pool it actually
creates legal problems because now the
defendant gets to claim that he can't
get a fair trial
so Trump shouldn't of said it but what
Trump said is of course what most people
believe Trump said yesterday for example
that we should just send the terrorists
to Gitmo most people in the United
States have not really considered the
legal ramifications of whether a green
card holder who's a terrorist should go
to Gitmo we already know an American
citizen who's captured overseas as a
terrorist cannot go to Gitmo in the
Hamdi case that which was during the
Bush administration but there are a lot
of Republicans who feel this way and it
is the passion with which from speaks
about these particular issues that
endears him to so many Americans who
feel that that Barak Obama the
Democratic Party have been soft on
terror for years
I would certainly consider that yes I
would certainly consider that you send
him to Gitmo
I would certainly consider that yes okay
so whenever first of all whenever he
says I would certainly consider that
that's him buying time to a certain
extent he doesn't know the answer so he
always says I'll consider it but even if
he says that you know the fact is that
people resonate to the fact that Trump
basically sees these terror attacks in
the same way that they do now the media
of course responds to all this how dare
Trump politicize how dare Trump
politicize we talked about this a little
bit yesterday but I just want to show
you the level of hypocrisy of the people
who have been calling Trump political on
these issues here's Andrew Cuomo the
governor of New York saying that these
these Trump tweets it's not the time now
to foment hate how dare he how dare he
politicize in foment hate I don't think
this is the time to get political we had
a policy and immigration policy in place
in the 90s it was a bipartisan policy it
was signed by a Republican president
there's no doubt that we have to be
smarter and have more intelligence but
there's also no doubt that this is not
the time to play politics this is not
the time to foment hate this is not the
time to divide because they all
exacerbate the situation right this is
the time to forge alliances with our
allies okay so it's not the time to
divide here's Andrew Cuomo on the radio
a couple of years ago their problem is
not me and the Democrats their problem
is themselves who are they are they
these extreme conservatives who are
right to life Pro assault weapon
anti-gay is that who they are because if
that's who they are and if they are the
extreme conservatives they have no place
in the state of New York yeah now we
can't be divisive right let's definitely
not be divisive right extreme
conservatives have no place in his state
Americans have no place in this day but
it's divisive for Trump to talk about
how
terrible the Democrats have been on
immigration really really terrible and
divisive here's Nancy Pelosi doing the
same thing it's inappropriate to get
political president Trump accused Chuck
Schumer and the Dems
for the terrorist attack the new in New
York in appropriate time of tragedy for
him to get political it's so
inappropriate says Nancy Pelosi here's
also a Nancy Pelosi said the very day of
Las Vegas shooting quote I urge you to
create a select committee and gun
violence to study and report back
common-sense legislation to help end the
crisis the bipartisan committee would
make recommendations to prevent
unspeakable tragedies such as the mass
shooting in Las Vegas so she was willing
to politicize the shooting in Vegas like
a month ago right but now how dare Trump
politicize how dare he politicized and
we talked about being divisive and
politicizing things your Trump he's so
divisive Chris math you don't have any
faith cuz Trump reigniting a civil war
it's crazy what do was you talking about
it's crazy guy get up a mnemonic ability
show come in talk about this crazy man
with it's crazy air go the politics the
mannerisms of this president are always
look for the partisan divide and if you
can if you're really lucky looked for an
ethnic divide if you can break it along
racial ethnic background lines it's a
winner for Donald Trump it just seems
like he always looks for the flip the
statues issue he's back in there again
with his chief of staff looking for
north/south blue-gray fighting against
her trying to reignite this reenact I
don't mind reenactors but he's trying to
reignite the civil war what do you make
in your fellow Republican he's trying to
reignite the civil war really like he's
bringing back slavery and then he's
going to embolden the people from the
south to fight the people from the north
that that's really his thing I do love
when the Democrats talk about how
divisive the Republicans are I'm playing
a clip of Michelle Obama yesterday ok
wanna talk about divisive rhetoric is
Michelle Obama one of the great uniter
of our time the unity figure I mean yeah
I know in 2008 she was saying that she
didn't love her country until Obama was
nominated but she's now a unity figure
itu a unifying force in America
here she is ripping on men that's one of
the questions is like raisin our men we
got to rest
it's like the problem in the world today
is we we love our boys and we raise our
girls you know we raised them to be
strong and sometimes we take care not to
hurt men and and I think we pay for that
a little bit and that's a wee thing
because we raisin them you know and it's
powerful to have strong men but what
does that strength mean you know does it
mean respect does it mean responsibility
does it mean compassion or are we
protecting our men too much so they feel
a little entitled and a little you know
you know a little self-righteous
sometimes but that's curran us to you
know raising our men to feel entitled
and self righteous because we've never
seen an entitled their self righteous
woman anywhere in America anywhere we
just can't find them Hillary Clinton we
can't find entitled self-righteous girl
anywhere yeah I just I don't see any of
them it's only men who are entitled and
self righteous and it's because we're
raising men to be this way right men are
the bad guys it's men who are the
problem in American society not women
yeah that's not divisive at all not
divisive at all okay so another issue
that where I think there's bipartisan
stupidity going on so there's a big
discussion now going on over internet
censorship and it's all based on the
2016 election there's been a lot of talk
in recent days about how Hillary Clinton
she was she was job basically by the by
the Russians the Russians use Facebook
and Twitter in order to push their their
own political agenda in order to push
political casts in the United States
there was a study that came out and said
that the Russians had I guess 150
million engagements on on Facebook and
and this was supposedly shifting the
election okay let me put that in
perspective okay I know my own Facebook
engagement numbers that's the so that's
you know how many they said the entire
election cycle I guess they had 150
million engagements something to that
effect and I want to look at the exact
statistic so I make sure that I get this
right
engagements Russian thoughts okay so
they say that 126 million people in the
United States may have seen post may
have seen posts presented by the Russian
government right maybe 126 million users
may have seen those posts okay my weekly
my weekly reach on Facebook from my
Facebook page alone is almost 30 million
so I do that every month
did I swing the 2016 election do I have
the numbers to swing the 2016 election
obviously not because if I did no one
would have voted right so that obviously
is not the case but what's amazing is
that the Democrats are so ensconced in
this idea that Hillary must have won the
election that they have to say that it
was the Russian BOTS that really won her
the election now now before I show you
what these idiot senators are saying and
I think it's from both parties the
stupidity I want to show you some of
what the Russian bots were putting out
that supposedly swung the election okay
so here is we're going to show a couple
of these graphics Austin can we get the
the Bernie Sanders graphic here the buff
Bernie so this is one of the Russian
fake pages okay it is an animated
picture of a very gay looking Bernie
Sanders doing a a muscle man pose in
multiple colors and it says LGBT United
you can color your own Bernie hero
there's a new coloring book called buff
Bernie a coloring book for Bernie acts
is full of very attractive doodles of
Bernie Sanders and muscle poses the
author of the book said she wanted
people to stop taking this whole thing
too serious the coloring is something
that suits for all people so first of
all the English and it is just atrocious
second of all did this shift the
election right this picture of Bernie
Sanders in a thong right an animated
Bernie Sanders in a thong that's what
shifted the election oh if only if only
we've been able to stop as sort of
nefarious activity by the Russians that
wasn't the only one it was we have any
more of these because they're really
absurd this one is from some sort of
group called American made and then it's
a picture of a father and a son both
carrying guns and it says this is the
way our children have to be raised it's
not the promotion of violence it's the
motion of confidence and the ability to
defend yourself or whatever it is and
that you know this was I think the
number of times these were clicked on
the first moments clicked on like a
hundred times this was clicked on like
800 times Wow
just shocking material it was this sort
of thing that shifted the election this
is my personal favorite I loved this one
so much okay this one was from a group
called army of Jesus and you can't see
it you should really check it out again
this is what Democrats are saying won
the election for Donald Trump okay it is
an animation of
eases wrestling with the devil and then
it says Satan
if I win Clinton wins Jesus not if I can
help it and then it says press like to
help Jesus win and then the caption says
today Americans are able to elect the
president with godly moral principles
Hillary is a Satan and her crimes and
lies had proved just how evil she is
again look at the grammar here right the
grammar isn't even English and even
though Donald Trump isn't the saint by
any means he's at least an honest man
and he cares deeply for this country my
vote goes for him okay so yes to
pro-trump ad look at the number of
shares at the bottom of this 29 shares
twenty-nine shares okay well no when I
put up a video we're talking thousands
and thousands of shares this is the sort
of stuff Democrats say shifted the
election and it's when we have to punish
Facebook and Twitter and Google because
if they had shut down the Russian basta
and Hillary certainly certainly would
have one here is Dianne Feinstein openly
threatening Facebook Google and Twitter
saying to them that if you don't find a
way to crack down on material we don't
like we will find a way to do it this is
a threat to the First Amendment what
she's talking about here you have a huge
problem on your hands
and the United States is going to be the
first of the countries to bring it to
your attention and others are going to
follow I'm sure because you bear this
responsibility you've created these
platforms and now they are being misused
and you have to be the ones to do
something about it
or we will okay you do something about
it or we will is the government
threatening regulation of an industry
that's not violating the law okay it's
not violation of the law for Russia
today to put out propaganda or for
Russian BOTS to put out propaganda or
for Russian groups to put out propaganda
it isn't the big problem here is not
that the Russians were trying to exploit
the system the big problem is that
Americans are gullible and will click on
anything that hits our buttons in the
right way okay I would venture to say
that if you're gonna talk about
propaganda the benefited the Trump
campaigns start with Infowars don't
start with Russia today right and if
we're gonna talk about propaganda the
benefited Hillary Clinton don't talk
about the Russians okay talk about the
talk about the ACLU I mean there are
groups in American life and the
Huffington Post
there are groups in American life that
put out material like this to try to
censor Facebook Twitter and Google and
suggest that it's their fault is really
absurd Tom cotton to the
same thing from the right again I like
Senator cotton but I think he's dead
wrong here thank you gentlemen for your
appearance this morning mr. edgy I want
to discuss Twitter's history of
cooperation with our intelligence
community last year in an open hearing
before this committee is been CIA
director John Brennan about Twitter's
decision to prohibit a subsidiary called
Data Miner from working with our
intelligence community director Brennan
stated that he was disappointed in
Twitter's decision but at the same time
we learned that we learned that Twitter
was refusing to work with CIA and the
rest of the intelligence community we
also learned that Twitter was pitching
Russia today in Sputnik propaganda arms
of the Kremlin to sell advertisements
for profit so in essence last year
Russia was beginning its covert
influence campaign against the United
States and Twitter was on the side of
Russia as opposed the national security
interests of the United States okay so
first of all if Twitter if there's if
there are Russians who want to put out
political messages you know the only
thing that's illegal here is if there's
actually like a campaign contribution
like the brushes making active campaign
contributions so they said we want to
back Trump and we want to put out ads
that's a violation of law by Russia
remember the idea that Twitter it has to
go like what if there's a Russian
citizen living an American citizen
living in Russia who wants to put out
these messages and if the messages are
exactly the same as messages they would
be put out by Team Trump or team Clinton
I'm let's put this way I am much more
worried about the government cracking
down on Facebook Twitter and Google than
M about Twitter Facebook and Google
somehow falling into the pocket of the
nefarious Russians to shift our election
system and I think we better be careful
with all of this okay time for some
quick things I like things I hate and
then I'll do a very quick Big Idea so
first things I like so I've been doing
books on children that are that are
really good
not by Kevin Spacey here's the book
nurture shock okay it's by Pope Bronson
and Ashley Merriman it's all about ideas
about what it is that makes children
grow in certain ways and it's sort of a
it's one of these pop social social
psychology books all about how children
grow and think it's really fascinating
they talk about whether children are
naturally racist the answer is kind of
yes they talk about what makes children
grow up smarter is it nature or nurture
and all of this is really fascinating
stuff and gives you some some pretty
solid hints as to how to raise your
travel to the most productive possible
way
this is not the only book I recommended
by PO Bronson and nationally Merriman
they wrote another one about competition
that I quite liked so this one is called
nurture shock po Bronson and Ashley
Merriman you can check it out okay other
things that I like you know what so
let's get the rest of things I like more
things I hate that's what the people
demand and they shall have it so I'm
gonna start with people targeting my
sister so my sister is not a public
figure she's a public figure in the
sense that she has her own career over
in New York she's an opera singer she's
a world-class opera singer she got into
USC after with a full scholarship after
singing for like a year she is she just
saying she starred in Aspen it the Aspen
Music Festival she starred in Mozart
Slocombe Clemenza di Tito over there
this is a clip of my sister Abigail
singing there Abigail was completely
non-political as far as I'm aware she
may disagree with me on certain
political issues but she certainly is
not part of the political debate
I hear here's a be singing from motor
and then I'll explain to you exactly
what happened here
[Music]
[Applause]
so she can see I mean she's super
talented right I mean she's obviously
great at what she does
the the alt-right got ahold of the fact
she's my sister I don't even I'm not
even friends with my family members on
Facebook because of this because I know
that there are people out there
targeting them people asked why my dad
who used to work at Breitbart was
writing under a pseudonym this is the
reason because I don't want people who I
love targeted by people who are
jackasses
they found my sister they targeted her
they spammed her entire YouTube every
YouTube video that she put up they
spammed with nasty and to openly
anti-semitic stuff about how she was a a
Jewish essentially and and they
targeted her this way they started
emailing her through her website they
targeted her on some of the neo-nazi
websites these people are scum and
anybody who has granted them an inch of
space is similarly scum so I just want
to call them out and and note you are
scum you are pathetic and the fact that
you you know sit in your in your
basements masturbating to anime does not
mean that that you are of worth in any
human level you use stupid despicable
human beings okay other things that I
hate so Stephen Colbert did an entire
stick yesterday because Donald Trump jr.
put out a tweet and the tweet that
Donald Trump jr. put out was a tweet of
his daughter and he said that he was
telling her that he was going to take
half her candy on Halloween to teach her
what socialism was okay you know kind of
funny and Stephen Colbert goes after
Donald Trump jr. as Stephen Colbert is
is apt to do last night Don jr. tweeted
a picture of his young
aughter holding her candy bucket and
said I'm going to take half of her candy
tonight and give it to some kid who sat
at home it's never too early to teach
her about socialism
yes it's never too early to teach kids
the danger of sharing on Halloween kids
literally go door-to-door to get free
candy from the neighbors because the
kids don't have it and the neighbors do
that that's socialism also give it to
some kid who sat at home you know
Halloween is fun right no child in the
history of child antara Lee missed
Halloween I'm worried that kid didn't go
out why is he okay is that child caring
for a sick parent you know it would be a
nice thing to do give him half your
Halloween candy okay so this is such a
mystery of socialism it's quite
astonishing so first of all Halloween is
not socialism and sharing is not
socialism voluntary sharing is not
socialism if voluntary sharing is not
socialism it's called charity we do it
all the time okay when you give out
candy on Halloween you're not being a
socialist you are sharing things okay
socialism is when the government forces
you to share things
socialism is when the government comes
in and mandates that you share your
candy Stephen Colbert you stupid idiot
okay the idea that that social image is
socialism is just sharing is belied by
only 100 million dead people over the
last century who failed to share
voluntarily enough and therefore were
taken off to the gulags or shot in in
mass graves so no not quite the same
thing as far as this idea that you know
there's a poor child in need and so you
should really give that child half your
candy again that's up to me I may agree
with you Stephen Colbert but the idea
that Donald Trump Jr's daughter should
have to give half her candy I think that
the better plan there would probably be
for Donald from Junior's very wealthy
man to to get that kid some candy if
that kid needs charity but I'm not going
to enforce it with the power of
government so again the deliberate Mis
read on socialism here it is pretty
astonishing and it just shows how the
left thinks about socialism they think
about it as a benevolent wonderful thing
that really has no downside you know
except for the whole we have to shoot
people if they refuse to abide by my
version of what charity ought to
constitute okay quick big idea here on
venture your show so every Thursday we
go through a big
idea one of the big ideas today we're
gonna do is start decisis so Clarence
Thomas did an interview with with Laura
Ingraham which is quite good yesterday
Laura clerked for Thomas on the Supreme
Court and Thomas was asked about his
judicial philosophy and I'm gonna
explain what differentiates Clarence
Thomas from Justice Scalia and why I
actually prefer Clarence Thomas to
Justice Scalia's jurisprudence even
though I love Justice Scalia's writing
philosophy it's described as
alternatively formalistic rigid strictly
conservative how do you describe your
philosophy justice I think it's get it
right it's the I think we are required
to reason to a conclusion and that's
what we try to do and try to do it in a
way that it is accessible to regular
people and when you read Thomas's
decisions first of all they are very
clear and they're very easy to read but
one of the things that differentiates
Clarence Thomas from from Justice
Scalia's Justice Scalia believed to a
certain extent in started decisis that
literally means the case has been
decided it's what we call precedent and
the problem with Justice Scalia's take
on this is that if you believe in
precedent you have to pick and choose
which precedent you choose to uphold but
you need to have a blanket rule that a
case that has been decided on similar
merits must stand or you can choose a
rule that says I don't care what the
case decided before if it's not right
then it's not right cases in which this
comes up roe v wade right do we abide by
roe v wade it's started decisis right
it's a case that's been decided about
abortion do we just abide by it or is
the case wrong Thomas would say I don't
care whether the case has already been
decided they got it wrong I'm gonna
overrule it the same thing holds true
for things like Dred Scott or Plessy to
be Ferguson or buck V Bell they're a
bunch of really bad cases in American
history Korematsu bunch of really bad
cases in American history do you just
abide by them because sorry decisis so
Justice Scalia never really had a
consistent rule as to which cases he
would abide by which precedent who'd
abide by Thomas does have a consistent
rule that rule is if the case is wrong I
overrule it and the case can be wrong
based on them getting the case wrong at
the time this is why I think that
Justice Thomas is actually a more
conservative justice more constitutional
justice than Justice Scalia even though
they voted together most of the time
Thomas's jurisprudence is I think more
solid and a better basis for for
constitutionalism than Justice Scalia's
even though I'm a big Scalia admirer
Scalia was quite brilliant okay so we'll
be back here tomorrow with the mailbag
if you want to be part of the mailbag
now is the time for you to subscribe to
go over and subscribe it's a Lee Weyer
and you can ask me any question that is
on your mind and we'll get to it
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]